before I introduce our final wrap-up
speaker who probably has the most
difficult task of the day I just think
this has been such an extraordinary day
and everybody has really worked hard
everybody in this room needs to give
themselves a round of applause because
while global partners has put together I
think an extraordinary program today it
would not have been extraordinary
without your participation and so for
our last formal aspect of the day today
we've asked my good friend Richard burr
fault who is a professor at Columbia
University Law School in fact he is the
Joseph Chamberlain professor of
legislation at Columbia Law School to do
the wrap up for us today and let me just
tell you a little bit about Richard who
probably won't tell you too much about
himself some people are tremendous
self-promoters other people just do a
lot Richard is one of those people who
just does a lot and not only is he a
successful law professor here at
Columbia University he did work in
government for governor you carry in the
state government of New York and he is
the co-author of state and local
government law which is a text that if
you go to law school in the United
States and are interested in municipal
and state law you will be reading
Richards book it's an extraordinary opus
and my son who has just started law
school apparently has been assigned this
book so he said isn't it's Richard for
fault don't we know him I said yes and
feel free to ask him any questions of
clarification Richards also done work in
campaign finance law and in the area of
our conference today urban economic
development he was one of the first
people to write about Business
Improvement Districts both from a legal
and political perspective and I think
he's gotten a lot of invitations to
speak as
of kind of transformative work in that
field from a legal perspective he's
actually currently working on a book on
campaign finance law a very dangerous
field and he is the vice chair of
citizens union a good government group
in New York he received his BA from
Columbia College and his law degree from
Harvard Law School which we say very
quietly around here and he is probably
one of the most creative intelligence
and nicest people I know at Columbia Law
School welcome Richard befall Thank You
Esther for that very generous
introduction and thank you to your son
for the royalties I don't get much but I
get something and that's as close as I
get to actually being an entrepreneur
and an innovator this really has been an
extraordinary day you can grind again I
congratulate you all for being here
after what I counted as one conversation
six panels what and one speaker and what
and one lunchtime speaker people who
hail from the speakers that we hear
today I'm not going to write love all
the mayor's again you've heard that many
times but the speakers I decide one by
my account it came from eight different
cities on five different continents so
really had an extraordinary array of
talent speaking to you today we should I
like to join again and thank in Columbia
University for sponsoring this nuke City
global partners the corporate sponsors
GE and the World Bank and i put in a
special thanks to our translators who
played a vital role of various points in
today's program went to begin with one
thought which is an American politician
he was the Speaker of the House
representatives named Tip O'Neill his
famous are saying all politics is local
so the first lesson I get from today is
that all economic development is local
or in we are due to pick up specifically
with our themes of today innovation and
entrepreneurship our local local in two
senses one which Sanjay prom our
luncheon speaker emphasized was that
development is local
and not national or that the real the
engines of development the engines of
innovation entrepreneurship are our
cities and for some of the reasons that
he as he pointed out to us no country
has achieved economic great economic
success without creating great cities
why cities as he reminded us again
cities for two things one is the cities
have particular density the
agglomeration of people of activities of
creativity these all matter cities are
the focal points of the exchange of
ideas of innovation of the particular
intensity of people consumers markets
that together promote entrepreneurship
and innovation and so in that sense
cities are essential cities are the
engines that these are the focal points
of innovation the other reason why we
might want to think about all innovation
as local support made by Jeff Immelt in
the conversation he had with Mayor
Bloomberg this morning which is the
notion that our markets are inevitably
local as he pointed out we don't have
one national health market we have 50
and probably the same could thing could
be said about many other pretty basic
markets cities are also economic arenas
each particular city or particular local
region I want talk a little bit more
about that later has its particular
needs its particular concerns its
particular customers its particular
cultures and it's out of this sort of
forcing arena that we get the innovation
the other way in which all economic
development is local is that cities are
all different one thing that was very
striking today is we listen to all the
different speakers although there were a
lot of common themes now get to those in
a second what was also striking that
there were different practices different
ideas different initiatives that we
really are have we really heard about
eight different laboratories and well a
lot of them try the same experiments and
got similar results some of them are
trying new experiments new things they
focus on different industries there from
way of pulling industries together
different uses of incubators or of tax
breaks or different focuses and so we
have both the similarity that they're
all coming from big cities really often
global cities focused on promoting
innovation yet and there were common
themes and what they did but also with
the thing that comes back as always
there's going to be differences so what
have we learned today we've learned a
lot about what local governments conduce
and sometimes we're moving now from I
think the notion that
innovation and entrepreneurship are
going to be local to a large degree to
the role of local government because I
think that was a really significant
focus both of our public sector speakers
and of our private sector speakers and
of the many people I'll get to that
later who bridge the public in the
private sector and I want to think about
I was really struck by the way in which
such a proton framed it as the three
different theories of what cities can do
I would vary that slightly and present
them not as alternatives but as a
spectrum things were from the least to
the most and we can debate about whether
the most is always appropriate and I
think there was the most debate about
the most but I think you can see them as
a range of possibilities one is the bare
minimum they get out of the way idea
which is to put in a more positive sense
and to pick up some of the statements of
Mayor Bloomberg and mr. melt at the
beginning of the day minimize
unnecessary regulation make sure
regulations serve their intended purpose
and don't do more get rid of unnecessary
permits yet and we heard a lot about
this this afternoon on in the discussion
about the developments in New York City
Department of Business Services think
about when there are multiple agencies
who have oversee the same function think
about when there are multiple
requirements that lead it or multiple
licenses and multiple permits that are
necessary for the same activity think
about that engage in regulatory reviews
see if we can strip down unnecessary
regulation and so we figure out which
regulations are unnecessary that's
probably the main point and then
simplify a regulatory system and also as
some as I think our speakers in the
morning conversation talked about have
reasonable tax policies so the very
least government should not get in the
way which is not to say the government
is always in the way but when government
does regulate for important reasons for
reasons of public safety or for consumer
protection for other purposes keep it to
them make sure the regulation does what
it's supposed to do and not more but I
think almost everybody here who spoke
was speaking about doing something more
than that although that's an important
basic minimum which we should never
forget but about doing something more
second was I guess is the field of
dreams model government is setting the
stage setting the framework creating the
conditions the general back
ground conditions for successful
economic activity some of the stuff is
at its most basic I think that may refer
to sound public finance basic physical
infrastructure roads and mass transit
and airports railroads and strong modern
information communication and technology
systems educational systems for a good
workforce housing adequate housing and
office space to make sure that there is
that there is space for economic
activity to occur and a theme that was
hit many times today quality of life
which is kind of an all encompassing
term but from again the most basic the
idea of clean and safe the city should
be clean and shitty cities should be
safe in should you should be attractive
places to more than that parks and
amenities the beaches of Tel Aviv to
having a vibrant cultural life because
in a world of mobile mobile capital and
mobile talent cities need to be the
kinds of places where people want to be
and can engage in economic activity so
that was sort of a second place along
the way and even that has its gradations
from I think the most basic of just
having two roads and an electric and
electrical systems two more more
stronger methods to promote local
cultural activities sponsoring special
events sponsoring Olympics sponsoring
entertainment improving parks next along
the spectrum is what I to use a word
that I hate it when people use it but it
has entered the vocabulary more
proactive it seems to me active is
active enough but I guess proactive is
probably the world we have to use they
are the word that came up the most today
was incubators I'm not sure anybody
actually quite defined with an incubator
was and I still think of little eggs and
that make chickens or something but I
think I get the idea that there are
emerging businesses or possible
businesses early ideas little eggs that
need some place to warm up and so they
need access as we were told about in in
in New York and in Cape Town and
elsewhere to a reduced cost office space
they need access to business equipment
and two computers that may be having to
sharing facilities you may not need to
be there for all day but yet part of the
day you need meeting space you need just
the basic again basic their physical
infrastructure
to get your business together and that's
something that cities can provide one
step up from that little bit more active
was training and mentoring and we heard
a lot about that today I think the
presentation of the hot bread kitchens
was really very fascinating about just
the very notion of people have a good
idea for a business but they don't they
may lack any skills in finance in
accounting in business planning in
marketing and this is something that
cities or other organization when it
gets in the minister who we talking we
say the city who do we mean exactly but
something that kind of resistance could
be provided in a very small scale these
basic training and mentoring and several
the speakers talked about this in
business skills then there was the thing
that I think kept coming up in different
ways it was all those see words that I
kept hearing convening connecting and
clustering so maybe one step more is
that cities and other supporters can
bring people together again there's a
little nervous about just how far people
a do that that they do that some of it
is physical in a building in a disused
market or in a region in the tech mile
in Tel Aviv are in business parks in
Stockholm they can bring people together
and who are they bringing together
business is getting brought together
with businesses so they can find
partners people who have a common just
in the same business or exchange
technology business being about the big
businesses and small businesses of big
businesses looking for something to
invest in small that can pick up some
tips and some skills established
businesses and startups new businesses
and lenders need to be brought together
each looking each looks one looking for
a source of capital the other looking
for an investment opportunity businesses
and nonprofits need to be brought
together on profits sometimes as
providers of additional assistance
sometimes as providers of capital a lot
we heard about business in universities
those speakers from Berlin were very
articulate about that connecting
universities and universities and
universities and businesses again as
sources of innovation sources of
information on ideas and of capital and
businesses and government business in
customers excuse me again different ways
in which what government can do in its
activities and it's convening and
connecting and clustering
is bring these different parties
together so that once they're together
they can exchange ideas they can
exchange information they can exchange
money all of which is important for
developing innovation and
entrepreneurship next thing the
government could do is and we heard a
lot about this this afternoon Wiz help
new businesses deal with government
itself thus in some ways is another
version of the reduced the amount of
government but there may be at some
point regulations are necessary there
are regulations that are necessary to
deal with land use planning and are
necessary for to make sure our buildings
don't fall down and that basic safety
requirements are met by people in the
food industry but they still have
permits and licenses and inspections and
something government can do is help new
businesses navigate this process as
navigators that the term I'm picking up
from the Department of small business
services but I think it's the right one
helping people who are new to the system
work the system they can also help with
there are many programs out there to
help new businesses federal state local
private so government can help them with
help them navigate the applications
process again we heard about this from
the hot bread kitchen as well one of the
things that the incubator can do is
literally sit down with people and help
them apply for monies that is available
to them for various government incentive
programs so government can help on that
government can do this in can help this
by developing good online programs
government can do this by good on-site
facilities government can do this by
creating specialized agencies that do
this like something like a department of
small business services which is
oriented to helping to convening and
connecting and navigating to get
businesses going not actually innovating
itself although these are in some sense
these are the government versions of
innovation government isn't in it one
thing that you learn today is that
government is also innovative and
entrepreneurial it may not be selling
things to the outset to the on the open
market but we heard a lot today was a
lot about innovative and entrepreneurial
government in service to or in
assistance to or facilitating innovative
and entrepreneurial business then the
further step along the spectrum and I
think here begins to get a little more
controversial is more direct government
assistance to businesses some of it
involves provision of land near extra
land at New York City is offering two
for the new school of engineering or
are sometimes the numbers number of our
speakers talked about in effect
repurposing land land that had
previously been used for manufacturing
or for industries that are dying or have
gone and making that land available to
new activities sometimes that could be
made broadly available as in some of the
incubators and sort of broader business
parks but sometimes we're talking about
providing it to individual firms
improvements to that land as well
infrastructure investments that are
targeted to helping a specific place and
then we also heard about capita and I
think they're there was probably the
most i wouldn't go disagreement exactly
but the most uncertainty as to what
extent should government be involved
making direct assistance to the new
businesses or maybe more properly i
think there's a lot of nervousness about
government taking on those kinds of
risks but maybe government doing it
through intermediaries government
providing some funds to not-for-profit
organizations which in turn raise other
funds and then themselves go ahead and
make the the the seed money grants or
the investments but i think it was as I
heard this today I think there was lots
of excitement and interest in
development and everything along the
spectrum then a little bit of
uncertainty about the variant and I
think that's something to take home and
think about what ways can we continue to
harness the assets that government
brings while checking the nervousness
about government playing favorites or
government or that being a more
politicized process next thought and
really just have a couple more one that
strikes me again is the multiplicity of
layers and this is probably just part of
the nature of urban life most of our
that I think the title of today was City
strategies and our focus was on cities
but lower the speakers were taking us i
would say higher and lower although
that's maybe a bad sense of hierarchy
smaller and bigger is probably more
accurate a number of our speakers we're
talking about really doing this at the
community level for some of our big
local cities like New York the city is
just too big to think about doing this
effectively the only cities has to be
the only entity for doing this something
some development occurs in communities
like the Union Square partnership and
presumably this is true of many of our
other big cities is you need to have
just as we say that the virtue of cities
that relative
to the nation-state is that they can be
attempted to two distinctive local needs
circumstances and preferences and
stakeholders so when within a big city a
neighborhood people who are at working
at the neighborhood level can even can
be attentive to the particular needs and
circumstances and preferences and
participants at that very local level
and so I think we need to have that
community-based level as well as a city
level and at the other end we need to
think about metropolitan regions number
of the speakers I think from Barcelona
in Lyon and Tel Aviv and Berlin talked
about even metropolitan regions or
states that encompass city's municipal
boundaries don't always match economic
regions in the United States they almost
never do the countries may be better at
this is now at being able to match
political legal and political boundaries
with economic and social entities we're
pretty bad at it and so it's one of the
things we need to think about none of
the speakers that address that is need
to create entities whether their
government entities or public private
entities that think bigger that address
some of the issues that should be
addressed broader so it may be that we
want some things that are working very
local and identifying small businesses
and some that are working much bigger in
terms of issues like infrastructure and
that gets me to know kind of a final set
of points one has to do with the the
entities we're talking about there is
what's again what is striking is the
variety of entities just as we could put
on a spectrum the different kinds of
things that we want to have that we're
talking about having done the actors
also could string out across the
spectrum from the purely public
Department of small business services a
city agency pointed by an elected mayor
to the purely private particular
organizations a number of cities New
York City partnership and and comparable
organizations elsewhere consisting
solely on the Barcelona global consider
solely of CEOs or executives of private
firms and hybrids public private
organizations where there where the
board members are both public and
private where the funding is both public
and private or even more complex
structures where cities create private
entities or mix or
for-profit entities create
not-for-profit entities this is a big
issue in the United States because the
tax reasons but it may be there may be
similar issues in other countries it's
the complexity of the arrangements I
think there's a tribute to the to the
innovative innovative of developments on
the in the public sector in thinking
about these things but that does mean
that we have a range of tools that can
be used depending on the kind of thing
you're thinking about provision of land
might be one thing provision of advice
might be something else provision of
capital might be yet something else
second next to final point is the need
for strategies one thing that the
speakers over and over again emphasized
the importance to have strategies that
will last in the medium and long run
whether that's creation of new
institutional structures like a new city
agency or a new public-private Local
Development Corporation or public
private corporation that can last for a
while whether it's creating new programs
whether it's focusing on specific goals
and different cities had different goals
in terms of what they want emphasize
some wanted to go into biotech so I
wanted to think about their University
some wanted to go into clean energy you
have to sort of we have to come up with
strategies which someone which may be
institutional some of which may involve
the targets of your spending different
cities argue articulated very different
focuses for where they want to put their
money in what kind of institutions they
want to use next to final point this has
to connect to other goals I think it's I
don't I think innovation
entrepreneurship are not are to some
extent their ends in themselves because
they obviously we're all concerned about
it the the jobs problem during the
current economic crisis but many of our
speakers and many of the programs they
discussed we're connecting them to other
things so Stockholm was talking to us
about clean energy and sustainability
Jeff Immelt was talking to us about
affordable health care because other
think about the presentation about the
hot bread kitchen I'm thinking about the
the social and economic integration of
immigrants or we heard about how many in
Nigeria how many everyday 250 new people
come into the major cities so a lot of
this is it's partly about jobs
partly about integrating newcomers into
the broader society and partly I think
as mayor bloomberg spoke at the very
beginning about the promotion of
economic diversity jobs in a variety of
areas not putting it all on an economic
monoculture because as we've seen
whenever that generally people have
tried that it's worked for a while and
then it doesn't work in the end we could
talk about Detroit and automobiles or we
could talk about people who put too many
eggs in the finance basket the final
thing and this is truly the last point
is what in the really attacking to the
first speaker of the day maybe the most
important thing is mindset or
institutional commitment I mean I was
checked by jeff immelt saying you were
serious about job to get up in the
morning and say what about jobs we
looked at I see the most successful
cities are the ones that purposely
created new institutions and purposely
or created new goals and said we want to
think about how our regulatory structure
impacts businesses we want to think
about how we are going to actually move
forward on something and that that I
think it's hard to institutionalize that
and I think that maybe is people
recognize we're all in a political
environment political environments are
subject to change and so I think maybe
the ongoing challenge for all the people
involved in this process is to
simultaneously get that mindset take it
seriously and then figure out ways of
institutionalizing it carrying it
forward maybe through into baby through
new organizations maybe through just
being successful enough that other
people feel obligated to carry it
forward by creating a brand that
recognizes it or maybe more by making
the political process more broadly
realize than it actually matters so it
has been a long day I think I want to
just say I'm what standing between you
and the end of the day but I'd be happy
to take any questions that you may have
or to direct them to the people who I'm
actually summarizing and paraphrasing
since this is all not so much me I think
as all the people I've been learning
from all day long
don't feel obligated to have questions
but if you do I'll be happy to take
that's right turn around and just say
first thank you to Richard that was
really extraordinary I don't know how
you did it but it was wonderful I hope
everybody feels really good about the
day today because we've clearly covered
a lot and I hope you get to take it back
to your cities and I know we New York
have learned tremendous amount from the
exchanges and I just wanna on behalf of
global partners Commissioner Marjorie
Tiffin and the mayor's office just to
thank everybody for participating in the
day today and to invite you who are
going with us on the bus to just meet us
on the bus downstairs and to everyone
everybody else thank you very much see
you shortly